كينيا تصف قرار روسيا
بإنهاء الصفقة بأنه طعنة في
ظهر أسعار الأمن الغذائي العالمي
وزارة الخارجية أشارت إلى غير
مناسب أه غير متناسب بل
تأثير القرار وكيف
سيؤثر على القرن الأفريقي والأرقام
هي  تم تصدير 33 مليون طن
من المواد الغذائية من
أوكرانيا في إطار المبادرة في عام 2023.
وقد اشترى برنامج الأغذية العالمي 80 في
المائة من قمحه من أوكرانيا
لعملياته الإنسانية،
وتم إرسال أكثر من 300 ألف طن إلى إثيوبيا
إلى كينيا وكذلك الصومال.
استمع إلى ما قاله الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة
بعد انسحاب روسيا من
الصفقة،
فالمشاركة في هذه الاتفاقيات في نهاية المطاف هي
خيار،
لكن الناس الذين يكافحون في كل مكان وفي
البلدان النامية ليس لديهم خيار،
مئات الملايين من الناس يواجهون
الجوع والمستهلكون يواجهون
أزمة تكلفة المعيشة العالمية
وسوف يدفعون الثمن،
لذا نسأل الليلة هل
سيدفع الأشخاص الأكثر ضعفًا في العالم الثمن النهائي، فقد حان
الوقت الآن لإحضار مايكل دانفورد إلى
نيروبي كينيا، وهو مدير شرق
إفريقيا لبرنامج الغذاء العالمي، وهي
منظمة دولية.  التي تقدم
المساعدة الغذائية في جميع أنحاء العالم، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك مايكل على انضمامك إلينا وقد
سمعنا التحذير من الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة
هناك، ونعلم أن هذا هو
السؤال الأول هل ستدفع الفئات الأكثر ضعفًا
الثمن النهائي
لانسحاب روسيا من صفقة الحبوب هذه؟
أعتقد أن هناك إمكانية أن
تدفع الفئات الأكثر ضعفا بالتأكيد ثمن
القرار الذي وصفه الأمين
العام بأنه مؤسف، وهو أمر
مؤسف للغاية بالنسبة للأشخاص الذين
يحاول برنامج الأغذية العالمي وغيره
الوصول إليهم.
أنا أجلس في نيروبي أقود برنامج الأغذية العالمي
وأحاول  الوصول إلى ما يزيد عن 47
مليون شخص، هذه منطقة بها ما
يقرب من 80 مليون شخص يعانون من
انعدام الأمن الغذائي الحاد وأي شيء بما في ذلك
هذه الصفقة التي تؤثر على توافر
الحبوب أو توريدها في جميع أنحاء العالم
أمر مؤسف للغاية،
إنه بالتأكيد أعني هل يمكن أن
تعطيني  إحساس بالوضع
الحالي للإمدادات من أوكرانيا، ما
تم إبلاغك به
جيدًا لأنه حدث بالأمس فقط، ما
زلنا نتعلم عن ماهية
التداعيات وما هي
الفرص المتاحة بشكل خاص
لاستئنافه في وقت ما  في
المستقبل القريب، ولكن كما قلت في
مقدمتك، يعتمد برنامج الأغذية العالمي بشكل كبير على
القمح الأوكراني، فقد قمنا بالفعل بشراء
أكثر من 80 بالمائة من قمحنا هذا العام، وقد
وصل معظمه إلى هذه المنطقة،
وهي منطقة
هشة للغاية على المستوى الإقليمي.  لحظة
بسبب الصراعات التي تحدث في
جميع أنحاء المنطقة بسبب آثار
تغير المناخ
وبسبب هذه الصدمة الاقتصادية والتي
تشمل تأثير الحرب في
أوكرانيا